they were married 15 years ago alfonse
d'amato had already left the US Senate
but remained a figure of power and
influence in New York politics I went in
his County gets elected or appointed
without his input now the de matos are
at war divorce is pending and the fight
over custody of their two children has
turned very ugly I feel really foolish
and I didn't see it but he kept a lot of
stuff secret in a federal civil rights
lawsuit filed last month mrs. D'Amato
claims her husband used his influence
with local police and authorities to
falsely imprison her for three days
against her will in a local hospital
psychiatric ward all to gain an
advantage in the custody case they ended
up taking you away cause you were
confined for three days is this you
think because your husband has the kind
of clout they'll do whatever he wants I
know it is it all goes back to an
incident at kotora de Matos home
involving police in September 2017 the
senator's wife showed us clips from
nandi cameras set up around her home
that she says back up her claims mrs.
D'Amato says she initially called police
because she thought she might have seen
a prowler on a back deck at one point at
least five officers from the Nassau
County Police Department were inside the
house apparently concerned there was a
weapon somewhere in the house so the
9-1-1 operator said are there any
weapons in the house I said yes there is
a lawful eeper there is a shotgun
lawfully purchase locked and secured in
my office closet with her arm in a sling
from recent surgery the surveillance
camera clips show her pointing police to
the closet where the gun was stored and
that an officer removing the gun still
in its original packing de Matos wife
says her 81 year old husband Alphonse
who soon emerges in his pajamas then
lobbied police to say she could be a
danger to herself or others because of
the gun and because he said she was
crazy off her drugs he lied about
several things but he started out by
saying Oh
she's crazy you know she's crazy and so
on Tom Liotta his cateura de Matos
lawyer he then said she takes lithium
and you know we all know that lithium is
generally taken for a bipolar disorder
which she does not have does she take
lithium no she takes she just takes
ritalin for a condition that she's had
since she was a child which is ADHD an
attention deficit disorder that's all
she's got but the senator said she takes
lithium right and then she's crazy
yes and and he also said that she had a
psychiatric history which she doesn't
have not at all not at all these are all
lies fabrications by him and this this
is what led to the police taking her to
the hospital because of what senator
D'Amato said to the police absolutely
that's what happened he just made that
up he just made it up all of this has
been playing out in the courts in Nassau
County where D'Amato first began in
politics and is still a revered figure
here when I caught up with him shortly
before the lawsuit was filed he said he
was just trying to protect his children
from his wife who he said had a
frightening episode
the safe environment and protected
[Music]
we appeared anyway and anybody who
suggests that actually mistaken it's for
Italy and I shouldn't be penalized
because I gave public appreciation yes
my mom many things but the fact of the
matter is that this matter
I asked him if he had tried to get the
police to think his wife was crazy on
the night they came to the house
senator you've heard that successful
that's repulsive it's repulsed
this is the model was watching as I
talked with her husband and heard his
claim that she had had a frightening
encounter the only frightening thing
that happened that evening was the way
he corrupted that police officers about
the need to do something which they all
know it was not to be done so it's
really not inappropriate so you're still
fighting still fight as alfonse d'amato
left in his chauffeured car we could all
see the VIP license plate on the back
number eight a symbol of the power and
influence he still wields in New York
State we asked senator D'Amato Florida
to come out our program or offer any
comment we've not heard back the offer
remains open but joining us now is
Thomas Lodi at hora de Matos lawyer who
filed this most recent lawsuit against
the former senator mister lady thank you
very much for being here Brian thank you
for having me it's a real pleasure this
is the model talks about the secrets
that he kept and is a reference in the
lawsuit to forged checks what's that all
about
well it's about the fact that in 2013
and 14 she found an account where mr.
D'Amato had forged her name to it and
forged her name to certain checks here
they are those doctors think about that
and that's not her signature no that's
not our signature these are forgeries
and unfortunately it had 39 million
dollars in that account which he had
used for campaign contributions and
personal expenses that's a crime isn't
it afford to check absolutely a crime
and should be investigated and
prosecuted is the FBI looking into this
for the FBI is looking at it and
hopefully as a result of this broadcast
they're going to move off a dime here
and do something about it because it
really needs to be done
mr. Gowdy there's also another video
that mrs. D'Amato made while she was in
the hospital recovering from shoulder
surgery so in the former senator in a
tirade against her shouting about her
with profanity
[Music]
[Music]
what's that all about she had spinal
surgery in March of 2017 just six months
before this incident 18 hours after the
surgery and mr. D'Amato got on the stand
and he said I love my wife
during this temporary custody hearing
that obviously is a lie
he's used to lying that's what he does
as a lobbyist in New York State and
throughout the nation but why show this
video it's a custody matter involves the
children are you're going too far do you
think no not at all because he has
indicated all along that he's never said
a bad word about his wife and yet he
broke his hand trying to assault her at
one point so she is a victim of domestic
violence and fraud and forgery and this
is just going on and on and on and the
court is not doing anything about this
and you're arguing that the court that
essentially the fix is in that he's got
too much clout there to have a fair
trial in this custody matter well his
son-in-law is a Supreme Court justice on
the same bench where this case is being
tried his daughter is employed or was
employed by the county of Nassau in that
case where ed Mangano was just invited
and convicted his grandson is an ad a an
assistant district attorney in Nassau
County
so his influence is far and wide
throughout the state throughout the
judiciary he engineered the endorsement
of the courts endorsement of this
particular judge who's trying this
matrimonial case which meant that the
voters had no choice about electing this
judge who was rejected by the voters
three times previously in judicial
elections you filed this lawsuit in
federal court or not in the state court
right we we've exhausted every
possibility in in state court for the
time being although there are several
appeal
that are pending there but we had to
reach out because there are
constitutional and parental rights that
are in jeopardy here civil rights and
parental rights are in jeopardy her
children are being hurt by what this
Court has done to her since October 5th
2017
it's outrageous what's going on and the
name of the courthouse where this
lawsuit has been filed Supreme Court
well the federal court is in the Eastern
District of New York in the United
States courthouse there and the state
court and the state court is Supreme
Court Nassau County the courthouse
building named well the federal
courthouse is named after Alphonse
D'Amato and he's obviously been
instrumental in creating the judgeships
for many of the people who occupy those
seats in the Eastern District of New
York oh you don't think very quickly you
can get a fair trial here I don't know
where I'm going to get a fair trial but
I keep trying I want to have this case
the matrimonial case moved out of Nassau
County and before a different judge
obviously we've tried that we've tried
to get stays and so forth so far we've
not succeeded but we're going to go
forward with our federal action
notwithstanding the fact that I've been
disqualified for bogus reasons in the
state Supreme Court action thomas leo d
thank you very much for being here we're
gonna stay on the story